now in Blackford has announced that he's
stepping down from his role as SMP
leader at Westminster and I can speak to
him now he joins me now in Blackford a
very good afternoon to you thanks so
much for talking to us so just a couple
of weeks ago you said that you would be
standing again for leadership at next
week's AGM so why have you changed your
mind
well I think a couple of things have
happened over the course of the last few
days of course we've had the Supreme
Court ruling last week that means that
we're not facing a referendum I regret
that next year we're now talking about
waiting till the next UK general
election in in 2024 if that's when it
comes but of course the first Minister
has also asked if I would take on a a
new role supporting the party and that
is reporting to her taking on a business
ambassadorial role and I think it's
really important that we have the
fullest engagement with the business
Community just a few short weeks ago I
published a paper on Scotland's energy
potential with the looking forward to
increasing our green energy output
five-fold creating 385 000 jobs
delivering four times as much energy as
we need and I'm just about to Embark in
a process of an industrial strategy
paper and I've want to make sure that I
can carry on doing that work but able to
engage with the business Community as
well it would have been difficult to do
that given much of that is going to be
back here in Scotland as well as leading
the the Westminster groups have signaled
to the group that now is the time to
think about the new leadership to take
us forward for the next stage of the
campaign for Scotland to become an
independent country I'm staying as
constituency MP for Roscoe Macabre I'm
looking forward to representing my
conceptions in Parliament but
complementing that was the role that
they the party has asked me to play back
here so it's an exciting development and
exciting opportunity and one I'm really
looking forward to engaging in fully
okay it sounds like you're going to be
very busy certainly but you'll be aware
I'm sure that there had been
speculations that there were MPS
plotting to have you replaced as group
leader there are some people saying that
you've jumped before you were pushed
what do you say to them
no and I you know I've taken the
decision I've been Westminster leader
for five and a half years I've very much
enjoyed the privilege of having that
role
um I mean of course it is one where you
really have to be at Westminster almost
all of the time and I've got the the
challenge of my commute from the North
End of the the Isle of the sky so I've
got the ability to balance the
responsibilities I have in the house but
taking on this partly role as well
um so you know it's it's a tough
decision to to make but there's one that
I did take certainly on the basis of the
the first Minister giving this
additional opportunity that I have so
I'll be supporting colleagues in
Parliament I'll support whoever the
group puts in place at the annual
meeting next week I had to make that
decision ahead of the annual meeting as
whether I I would be standing or not and
I think it's right with a few days to go
that a signal that we're moving on to a
new phase one that I can assist with the
independence campaign here in Scotland
continue to play my role in Parliament
and support the leadership that the
group puts in place suggestions that the
person most likely to have got the
numbers is Stephen Flynn is that what
you're hearing and will you back him as
the next leader at Westminster
I will back whoever the the group
chooses at the annual meeting next week
I don't know who's going to be on the
the ballot paper we'll wait and see her
but I will happily support whoever the
group elects as leader next Tuesday
and you did say I think at one point
that you want to
send free lead
any regrets
no I absolutely not I'm really excited
about the the opportunity that I've got
I'm going to be working with colleagues
right across the party working with
colleagues in the group but of course
working with the first Minister who's a
very dear colleague and friend and I'm
really looking forward to being part of
the team and being her Ambassador in the
business Community making sure that
we're driving on support for
Independence and that we that we
complete this journey with Scotland
becoming an independent country that's
what I want to see happen and I'm
delighted that I've got an opportunity
to play the part that the first Minister
has asked me to do how does she react to
you saying you were stepping down
um I think you know we all recognize
that there's a big job to do in in
taking forward this case
um I I know I've worked very closely
with her
um I've always supported the Scottish
government I'll continue to do that but
um I think she recognizes that it is
right to take the decision that we move
on that we refresh that we have a new
leadership team and I stand shoulder to
shoulder with her and making sure that I
do what I can in the business Community
to make sure that we drive the case for
Scottish independence that's what I'm
looking forward to very much looking
forward to finishing the story Scotland
becoming that independent country making
sure that we can drive that green energy
potential that we can get that green
industrial transformation in Scotland
drive-up jobs okay drive up living
standards and have a a better Scotland
sorry to rush you in Blackpool we're
running out of time we're about to
finish the program but we appreciate
your time this afternoon thanks so much
for talking to us today